Nancy Rios: Gonna go ahead and… Move on…
Nancy Rios: So, the whole program, does come down to two things, and that's,
Nancy Rios: that, that they kind of make the experience happen, so it kind of just needs to happen in order, because you can't, like, own your search if you don't know your niche. So we kind of intentionally built this program this way. So, level one.
Nancy Rios: will be Know Your Niche. This is gonna be the first 3 weeks.
Nancy Rios: Know Your Niche is the answer to, like, a simple question of, like, what kind of, work are you a strong fit for, and why?
Nancy Rios: like, being very specific about… about that thing, right? Not just, like, I want a job in tech, or I want a job in environmental science, or what have you. So, finding, like, truly, like, being very specific about, like, who you are, and why you are a strong fit for
Nancy Rios: for the job. And then moving on to Level 2.
Nancy Rios: this is more, as to where, like, what we just talked about, right? Like, the founder's mindset, now you're just putting in the work. You run, like, your search, as, like, a weekly cycle,
Nancy Rios: you're able to find jobs and make adjustments as needed. You kind of, take action.
Nancy Rios: And start applying to those jobs that you, that you found.
Nancy Rios: Okay, any questions with, the experience?
Nancy Rios: No? Okay.
Nancy Rios: Yeah, so, like I mentioned, in the first 3 weeks, you will be developing your niche, and by the end, you will have, handful of specific roles and types that you are targeting. You'll have a clear statement as to why you're a fit for the work that you're wanting to do, and then, moving on to the Own Your Search.
Nancy Rios: you actually put in the work, and you run your search, in a weekly cycle. You'll do that at least 3 times.
Nancy Rios: So by the end, you'll have job postings, but also you will have practice. And, hopefully you keep using,
Nancy Rios: The work that you've been doing, now on your own, after the 6 weeks.
Nancy Rios: Okay.